dank für die charmante ankündigung wenn
ich an braunkohle denke dann denke ich
an haar weg das habe ich mir auch anders
vorgestellt aber
ich komme darauf zurück denn es ist
natürlich im gewissen sinn ein leitmotiv
dass wir in diesen zeiten erleben dass
eine art ungleichzeitigkeit herrscht und
die macht es natürlich schwierig die
richtigen politischen entscheidungen zu
kommunizieren durchzusetzen
möglicherweise aber auch die richtigen
unternehmerischen entscheidung zu
treffen und über alles gelegt ist das
vielleicht die herausforderung neben all
den konkreten herausforderungen auf die
ich eingehe diese ungleichzeitigkeit und
vielleicht darf ich persönlich beginnen
sie hatten jetzt eine dreitägige
konferenz in einem lichtdurchfluteten
saal und na ja man hat nicht parteitage
hatte dann war man nach drei tagen
irgendwie auch durch und das einzige was
einen noch manchmal wieder wach gemacht
hat oder jedenfalls aufmerksam gemacht
hat weil das persönliche und nicht noch
einmal abspulen dass hier vielleicht in
regen in verschiedenen variationen schon
15.000 mal gehört haben und so möchte
ich vielleicht beginnen als letzter gast
hier auf ihrer tagung dass ich einmal
noch persönlich anfange um zu erinnern
was eigentlich gerade passiert und vor
welchem hintergrund ihre konferenz der
tagung der tag der industrie stattfindet
wo wäre ich im hintergrund wir aber auch
die politischen debatten führen wenn ich
manchmal habe ich zeit am sonntag und
gehen noch länger trocken und es gibt
einen podcast den ich dann manchmal
meistens höre der heißt crane cast von
der bbc ich würde sagen ein
journalistisches meisterwerk mit
verschiedenen geschichten aus der
ukraine aber auch russischen geschichte
und diese geschichten sind geschichten
aus dem krieg zum beispiel wurde und man
läuft durch den wald hätte maniche
kopfhörer im ohr würde man die vögel
singen hören man sich das gebrochene
licht also das was ich als einen schönen
vielleicht eine erhabene moment
begreifen würde man hört dann die
geschichten die quasi gleichzeitig
passieren von einer familie junge mutter
junger vater zwei töchter bombenangriff
sie fliehen vor den bomben der vater und
die tochter einer tochter werden getötet
die sitzen danach die familie die mutter
und die überlebende tochter über tage im
bunker und sie bitten die ukrainischen
oder die russischen soldaten ich weiß
gar nicht wer den mann und die tochter
endlich zu beerdigen und das geht nicht
weil keiner rauskommen kann man hört von
einer frau die in einem roten mantel das
war wohl eindringlich erschossen wurde
mit einem schuss ins gesicht getötet
wurde und weil die situation so brenzlig
ist immer wieder überfahren wird von
autos man hört geschichten von einem
jungen soldaten 19 jahre alt der nach
schwerer verletzung wieder an die front
geht und dann von diesen bbc leuten
gefragt wird was ist deine hoffnung und
er sagt nicht frieden sondern er sagt
ich möchte einmal noch im mittelmeer
baden und kriegt dann eine einladung von
einer frau die ein sommerhaus auf
teneriffa hat ist das nicht das
mittelmeer aber so solche geschichten
werden dort dargestellt und man hört die
und versteht auf einmal wieder was
eigentlich phase gerade in europa ist
und was gerade phase in unserer welt ist
dass putin nämlich einen krieg vom zaun
gebrochen hat aus meiner sicht weil er
die individuelle freiheit von menschen
nicht ertragen kann und weil die ukraine
in dem bestreben nach freiheit eine
bedrohung für ein diktatorisches regime
geworden ist die darf nicht erfolgreich
sein die freiheit die offene
gesellschaft das individuelle glück
streben von menschen darf für diktatoren
nicht erfolgreich sein deswegen hat er
diesen krieg angefangen weil diktatoren
die freiheit fürchten und deswegen dafür
diesen krieg nicht erfolgreich
abschließen weil das bedeuten würde dass
diktatoren die freiheit immer wieder
erfolgreich angreifen können das ist der
hintergrund aller unserer debatten und
auch noch einen nach mehreren hundert
tagen oder nach 120 30 tagen ich weiß
gar nicht genau dürfen wir nicht
vergessen was eigentlich gerade der
grund für diese anstrengenden
schwierigen und notwendigen debatten ist
die wir führen und ich finde es hat sich
noch etwas verändert in der jüngsten
zeit zuerst haben wir uns und ich habe
mich mehrfach dafür bedanken für die
solidarität der deutschen bevölkerung
der verbrauchern der verbraucher die die
hohen energiepreise tragen die die hohe
inflation tragen müssen der
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer die
diese aktion mitgemacht haben aus
solidarität mit der ukraine wegen diesem
angriff auf die freiheit
aber ich denke was wir gesehen haben in
der letzten woche ist noch mal eine
andere dimension
die reduktion der gaslieferungen durch
ios 4.1 ist eben auch ein angriff auf
uns ein ökonomischer angriff auf uns und
das problem in seiner petersburger rede
in einer art orwells neusprech alles
verdreht hat also krieg zufrieden
erklärt hat unfreiheit wilke diktatur
zum eigentlich zu bevorzugen
gesellschaftsmodell zeigt nur wie
bewusst dieser angriff erfolgt wie
funktioniert dieser angriff und wir
haben das musste jetzt mehrfach schon
gesehen durch die reduktion von
gaslieferungen an bulgarien an polen an
dänemark dann den versuch mit zwei
discjockeys als geschäftsführer von
gazprom germania chaos am europäischen
energiemarkt zu stiften dann mit der
sanktionierung von gazprom germania der
das muster es immer das gleiche die
menge zu reduzieren die preise nach oben
zu drängen um und das ist ja nicht
zufällig um in europa und in deutschland
eine debatte auszulösen über not und
über angst die hier dieses land trifft
und damit meine ich nicht mit einer
debatte den streit den demokratischen
notwendigen streit und die richtigen
antworten die wir darauf geben müssen
das schließt meinetwegen auch debatten
über die richtige form der
energiesicherheit mit ein das muss
natürlich eine demokratische
gesellschaft miteinander diskutieren
auch öffentlich diskutieren wenn die
argumente stichhaltig sind muss man sie
gegen das licht halten und dann auch
wegen das ist nicht das was ich damit
meine mit einer streitbaren gesellschaft
sondern eine gesellschaft die um die
prinzipien streitet ob die unterstützung
nicht der ukraine sondern der freiheit
richtig ist dass soll unterbunden werden
denn durch die materielle not durch die
hohe inflation
hohen inflation die hohen energiepreise
haben natürlich menschen angst angst vor
armut angst vor wohlstandsverlust angst
dass was sie sich aufgebaut haben in
einem langen leben vielleicht nicht
halten zu können angst vor
arbeitslosigkeit unternehmerinnen
unternehmer die sagen aber das ist mein
familienmodell meine familienfirma die
hat nicht geerbt ich habe eine aufgabe
sie die zukunft zu führen ist das denn
alles noch richtig und dann geht es
nicht darum den wohldosierten streit
über die richtige antwort zu führen
sondern dann geht es darum die frage zu
stellen ziehen wir uns zurück soll putin
gewinnen dann macht man den raum auf für
populismus da geht es nicht mehr um den
demokratischen streit sondern nur noch
um den debatten raum für den und das
darf ich in diesem fall sagen rechten
populismus und es ist kein zufall dass
ist eine strategie und diese strategie
darf nicht erfolgreich sein deswegen hat
sich etwas verändert es geht nicht nur
um die solidarität mit dem teil
es geht eben auch darum dass wir unser
verständnis von politischer kultur einer
offenen gesellschaft einer freien
marktwirtschaft verteidigen
ungleichzeitigkeit sehr geehrte damen
und herren sie betrifft eben auch die
vorsorge draußen nähern wir uns wieder
30 grad das ist sommer endlich mal
wieder ein sommer trotz sommerwetter und
noch nicht überstanden der pandemie war
man hat wieder das gefühl man kann
einigermaßen unbeschwert unterwegs sein
man kann wieder feste feiern die fia
gegen den garten haben offen wer wollte
nicht im sommer einfach genießen und wir
machen uns gedanken über den nächsten
winter und überlegen welche maßnahmen
wir tun müssen wenn es wieder kalt wird
das ist weit weg von der
lebenswirklichkeit von den meisten
bürgerinnen und bürgern heute aber es
ist dennoch eine notwendige debatte sie
haben gefragt was passiert wenn der
gashahn zugedreht wird und noch einmal
wir reden nicht mehr darüber dass wir
den gashahn zudrehen diese debatte
hatten wir und ich stelle mit einer nein
keine erstaunt fest aber ich stelle fest
dass die stimmen die vielleicht vor drei
monaten gesagt haben ja machen wir doch
sofort ein gas embargo 2%
wachstumsverlust das werden ja wohl
schon verschmerzen können die habe ich
jetzt in den letzten zwei wochen nicht
mehr gehört offensichtlich weil das
argument sich auch nicht als besonders
tragbar erwiesen hat wir reden darüber
dass der angriff mit energie als waffe
gegen uns geführt wird und das muss man
klar sagen wir verfolgen einen plan seit
beginn des krieges dieser plan bedeutet
die
unabhängigkeit von russischen zufuhren
möglichst schnell herzustellen
schrittweise dafür zu sorgen natürlich
auch um möglichst wenig euros oder
dollars an putins überweisen aber vor
allem oder von anfang an die haupt
überlegung vor allem um nicht in einer
essbaren situation zu sein dieser planen
sie kennen ihn bedeutet in windeseile
aufbau von energie infrastruktur
bedeutet andere gaslieferanten zu finden
auf dem globalen markt dieser plan
bedeutet die energie-effizienz hoch zu
halten die mengen zu reduzieren
dazu gehört dann auch jetzt wo die menge
von nord stream 1 noch mal um 60 prozent
zurückgegangen ist gaskraftwerke die im
strombereich unterwegs sind aus dem
markt zu drängen durch die hereinnahme
von kohlekraftwerken das ist der plan
aber es ist ein ehrgeiziger plan es gibt
natürlich gar keine garantie dass er
aufgibt es gibt nur ein hohes eine hohe
an hohen druck dafür zu arbeiten dass er
aufgeht wenn er aufgeht sind die
speicher im winter voll und wir haben
zwölf bcm als kapazität an den lng
terminals angeschlossen und haben dann
im nächsten frühjahr im mai im juni die
nächsten +20 bcm dar das gibt uns eine
gewisse hoffnung dass wir das überstehen
können aber noch einmal make no mistake
das ist noch nicht erreicht und die
speicher sind nur bei knapp 60 prozent
und wenn wir nur mit halbvollen
speichern in den winter gehen und die
der gashahn abgedreht wird dann reden
wir über eine schwere wirtschaftskrise
die deutschland trifft über politische
maßnahmen die schwer einschneiden die
man wo man nichts mehr richtig machen
kann und deswegen ist dieses reden über
umfragewerte und über politische
zustimmung zu personen auch zu meiner
völlig unangemessen wenn wir in vier
jahren das ist überstanden haben dann
können wir darüber nach rehden wieder
guten job gemacht hat aber wir reden
hier um eine politische situation und
eine ökonomische situation die schlimmer
werden kann als die korona pandemie und
das ist glaube ich nicht allen klar was
hier gerade verhandelt wird wenn es
darum gehen würde dass bestimmte
industriekomplexe die vielleicht
besonders abhängig von gas sind für eine
woche kein mehr gasversorgung haben
würden dann würde ich sagen okay das
kriegen wir schon hin das können wir
auch über brücken finanzieren das
überleben wir aber wir reden ja über ein
szenario das möglicherweise über monate
andauert und dann reden wir nicht mehr
darüber dass vielleicht die
der shareholder value in dem jahr 22 23
etwas zurück gegangen ist sondern dass
die unternehmen einfach weg sind und
dass das zu verstehen und die
notwendigkeit hinter all
den debatten die wir moment führen die
wichtigkeit nochmal einzuführen das
glaube ich kann nur gelingen wenn es
eine kollektive debatten anstrengungen
gibt die die wirtschaft und die politik
mit einschließt wir haben also viel
aufgaben vor uns und viel zu tun
das gute ist wir haben uns darauf
vorbereitet und wir arbeiten entlang
eines planes der ich das so sagen
täglich besser wird und das liegt auch
daran dass viele unternehmen viele
verbände der bdi mit hilft diesen plan
besser zu machen
hat sich minister wurde gab es eine
runde mit dax vorständen und ich ende
noch wie ich fragte worüber reden wir
also das war noch vor dem krieg was was
ist die was ist die erwartung und es gab
so viele erwartungen irgendwann an einer
der teilnehmer gesagt wissen sie was das
ist eine besondere runde denn hätten wir
uns vor fünf jahren getroffen hätten wir
alle gesagt wir reden darüber dass sie
sich bitte raushalten aus 1 1
wirtschaftsministerium es dann ein
erfolgreiches wirtschaftsministerium
wenn es sich nicht einmischt und im
westen die förderbescheide raus gibt
aber dieses verständnis von
wirtschaftspolitik als wirtschafts
förderbescheid verteil politik dass es
erkennen da vorbei und umgekehrt brauche
ich natürlich brauchen meine leute die
expertise aus ihren unternehmen die
daten für die versorgung aber auch das
denken in modellen um unsere arbeit zu
überprüfen das ist eine gewisse form von
korrupten von kooperativ muss der
deutschland stark gemacht hat als
normalform dass man mit den verbänden
gewerkschaften würde ich es einfach mit
einbeziehen versucht hat die beste
lösung dem besten weg zu finden da darf
nur nicht missverstanden werden
natürlich gibt es verschiedene
interessen auch politische sozial
politische interessen möglicherweise
wettbewerbs politischer interessen aber
was ich besonders zu schätzen weiß ist
und so scheint es mir dass wir uns dafür
das war in meiner sprache sagen nicht
gegenseitig verarschen und das ist die
bedingung dafür dass es gut läuft das
wenn sie sagen wenn ihre unternehmen
sagen wenn der verband sagt die idee ist
theoretisch gut aber sie wird nicht zu
dem ergebnis führen dass du dir
vorgestellt hast du musst noch mal ran
und nachher sitzen dann tun wir das weil
ich das gefühl habe es ernst gemeint das
geht nicht darum dann weniger gewinne zu
haben sondern das ernste anliegen ist
wirklich besser zu machen und ich hoffe
das hier ist genau so gut ich es genauso
gut zurück spiele und sage wenn wir
bestimmte sachen politisch nicht gehen
dann liegt es nicht daran dass irgendein
parteiprogramm von 2017 den im wege
steht sondern weil wir es überprüft
haben und wir zu anderen ergebnissen
gekommen sind und wenn sie an ergebnisse
haben dann reden wir darüber aber wir
dürfen uns in dieser lage wir müssen uns
in dieser lage vertrauen und nicht
versuchen zu übervorteilen und genau so
erlebe ich diese zeit und dafür würde
ich nicht einmal ganz herzlich bedanken
ungleich
ungleichzeitigkeit also verschiedene
dinge die scheinbar widersprüchlich sind
stehen nebeneinander gilt natürlich auch
für das was sie mit der braunkohle
anmoderation genannt haben gemacht haben
ja es stimmt wir müssen getrieben durch
die not des tages jetzt wieder mehr
fossile energien verbrennen und in den
markt bringen als wir eigentlich wollten
und das ist die canon ein parteibuch
eine sehr schlechte nachricht was war
kein guter tag für mich am sonntag als
wir das entschieden haben gleichwohl
notwendig weil es darum geht und ich
habe es eben ja schon skizziert eine
schwere ökonomische krise abzuwenden von
der gesellschaft von deutschland ich
würde noch einmal sagen weil immer
gesagt wird ja die wirtschaft die
wirtschaft das sind natürlich der bdi
und seine vertretung aber die wirtschaft
das ist dieses land das sind die
arbeitsplätze der menschen das sind die
einkommen der menschen das sind die
güter des täglichen bedarfs also wenn
wir von einer wirtschaftskrise reden
dann reden wir nicht von
aktion notierung sondern wir reden
darüber dass wir am täglichen bedarf
mangel haben das abzuwenden erzwingt
dann eben solche schritte aber das sind
schritte die nur zu den nächsten
größeren schritten auf fordern und sie
notwendig machen und diese schritte sind
gebunden an die zweite große krise
strukturelle krise unserer zeit nämlich
ein starkes reiches kräftiges
industrieland zu dekarbonisierung und
das ist die aufgabe die über dieses jahr
und über das nächste jahr über diese
legislaturperiode hinaus reicht und es
ist eine aufgabe an der wir wachsen
können eine aufgabe wo sich die debatte
in den letzten jahren komplett
verwandelt hat das mir große ehemalige
kohleverstromung unternehmen sagen wir
wollen schneller sein wo ist die
wasserstoff regulierung wo ist der
ausbau von wasserstoff die menge an
erneuerbaren energien die in den markt
erreichen nicht das zeigt doch
eigentlich wo wir angekommen sind ich
weiß auch so vielen veranstaltungen mit
der wirtschaft nicht einmal musste
überzeugungsarbeit leisten dass die
neuen techniken die neue form von
produktion das umstellen auf die
carbonisierung noch argumentiert werden
muss dass ob es längst entschieden wir
sind längst schon im wettlauf wer die
besten antworten nach vorne bringt und
das wiederum ist und ich sollen nicht
zynisch klingen ich habe das hoffentlich
deutlich gemacht wie angefasst ich auch
persönlich bin durch diesen krieg den
putin über europa gebracht hat und
nichts ist zu beschönigen an dieser zeit
deswegen will ich kein zynismus
missverstanden haben aber natürlich ist
es auch so dass unter dem druck des
tages bestimmte dinge möglich sind die
davor als unmöglich gedacht worden oder
schienen volker wissing hat das eben
auch gerade mit dem neuen euro ticket
genannt und ich weiß dass es das neun
euro ticket wie anders denn mit der
chemischen industrie mit der
stahlindustrie mit der energieversorgung
wo es wirklich um milliardensummen und
große infrastrukturprojekte gibt wenn
wir es schaffen unter dem druck des
tages und unter dem gemeinsam geteilten
wissen was eigentlich der energie- und
wirtschaftspolitische fahrt ist jetzt
alten midi-tower wegzublasen und
schneller zu werden dann ist da
natürlich auch die chance für eine
bessere zukunft drin in dieser zeit und
ich glaube genau das passiert im moment
und genau das ist die antwort auf die
vierte ungleichzeitigkeit wir haben sie
haben volle auftragsbücher und eine
angst vor rezession
wir haben einen fachkräftemangel und
einen hohen bedarf an neuen
arbeitskräften und arbeitsplätzen wir
sind ein attraktiver standort große
unternehmen kommen nach europa batterie
unternehmen halbleiter und industrie und
gleichzeitig gibt es die große sorge
dass die nächsten monate und in die
rezession führen diese
ungleichzeitigkeit sie lässt sich
auflösen durch politische und
wirtschaftspolitische handlung es sind
keine unüberbrückbaren gegensätze aber
sie werden eben nicht von alleine sich
auflösen sondern nur durch das
gemeinsame tun und das definiert die
wirtschaftspolitische agenda dieser zeit
dieses tages dieses jahres dieser
legislaturperiode
letzten punkt geben sie mir gemacht
[Applaus]
nach leichen eigentlich heißt es immer
mal wieder dabei helfen sie mir noch ich
habe mir das überlegt was ich sage ich
mir okay
einmal will ich 44 punkte dann bin ich
durch zwei minuten ja ich war schnell
erstens lassen wie gehen wir mit der
inflation um diese inflation ist vor
allem eine energiepreis getriebene
inflation das gibt eine spezifische
antwort notwendigkeit die über die
klassischen mittel inflation zu
bekämpfen nämlich durch geldpolitik
hinausreicht sie bedeutet dass wir die
förderung für zukünftige märkte für
zukünftige märkte nicht zurücknehmen
dürfen wir müssen jetzt in der krise das
schaffen das den wohlstand in die
zukunft sichert umgekehrt heißt das dass
die überforderung und das darf ich
vielleicht sagen die ich in
verschiedenen programmpunkten auch in
meinem ministerium dauernd feststellen
dass die überforderung zurückgenommen
wird also eine neuausrichtung der
förderpolitik wenn ich es so sagen darf
in einer marktwirtschaft in subventionen
immer das letzte mittel das heißt der
markt funktioniert noch nicht aber neue
märkte zu erzeugen das ist die aufgabe
der richtigen teurer politik daran
arbeiten wir zweitens mehr energie auf
den markt bringt natürlich erstmal
diversifizierung lg aber auch mehr
erneuerbare energien mit einer ich würde
sagen affenartigen geschwindigkeit
drücken wir die gesetzlich erst durch
die parlamente um den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien zu beschleunigen
das soll sich dann in der nächsten
jahreshälfte fortsetzen für wasserstoff
für die elektrolyse für die pipelines
und so weiter
vierter punkt die
reform von verwaltungsprozessen wir sind
zu langsam wir planen zu langsam jedes
gesetz für sich genommen jede vorschrift
für sich genommen hat natürlich ihren
sinn aber zusammengenommen bis zu einem
gewissen unsinn wenn dinge oberleitungen
für züge volker bis ins projekt 40 jahre
bauen weil wir ja schon tot was soll das
denn das kann ja nicht das kann ja nicht
funktioniert die windkraftanlagen sechs
bis acht jahre brauchen dann könnte ich
2030 nur windkraftanlagen im land ziehen
die jetzt schon beantragt sind die gibt
es aber gar nicht das kann also an nicht
aufgehen also muss es schneller werden
und ich glaube das beste was wir tun
können ist an gruppe am konkreten
beispiel und zu lernen und dann cluster
artig uns vorarbeiten nicht eine
allgemeine verwaltung sin
bürokratisierung stabat die dann nur
mehr zur bürokratisierung führt also
etwas geduld für die ihnen noch warten
müssen aber im konkreten wie bei allen
die bei wie bei windkraft und als
nächstes die wasserstoff projekte
konkret nach vorne gehen und die
blockaden lösen gegen ihn im weg stehen
und letzter punkt und damit bin ich
wieder am anfang das was wir erleben ist
eine system rivalität nicht in bezug auf
russland aber in bezug auf china hieß es
immer china partner
konkurrenzsystem rivale wir müssen
ehrlich sein die partnerschaft ist arg
strapaziert natürlich sind das große
absatzmärkte und große
rohstofflieferanten märkte aber wir
wären blind und würden nicht erkennen
was die geopolitische situation ist wenn
wir nicht vor allem die system rivalität
anerkennen würden das heißt wir brauchen
neue import und neue exportmärkte das
heißt wir müssen an der idee von handel
und globalisierung festhalten wir müssen
aber auch sie strategisch nutzen
strategisch nutzen heißt dass sie nicht
gegen unsere werte arbeitet selbst gegen
unsere werte arbeitet sondern dass wir
dir handelsabkommen nutzen um unsere
werte in der welt zu mindestens zu
befördern durchzusetzen ist vielleicht
ein hehrer anspruch
gleichzeitig allerdings uns auch
eingestehen politisch wie als
unternehmen dass wir die
diversifizierung also das breite
aufstellen von rohstoff ketten von
energie abhängigkeiten und so weiter zur
maßgabe machen so kann daraus ein schuh
werden dass wir unseren einfluss in der
welt nutzen gleichzeitig ein bisschen
unabhängiger werden von den bösen
absichten von diktatoren in der welt
vielen dank
der katholizismus wird zur
unterschichten religion
die protestanten sind in der regel
sozial besser gestellt und das soll auch